A smart phone app that can send smells, and
this bridge concept for a river in Paris is
an inflatable trampoline!
Vsauce. Kevin here! This is Mindblow.
This simulation shows an updated theory on
the formation of the Moon as made up of Earth
parts. A very fast, spinning Earth collides
with a planet nicknamed Theia. Theia is mostly
vaporized along with part of our planet, with
some material escaping Earth and forming a
huge disk around it, eventually forming the
Moon, and this could explain how the Moon's
composition so closely matches that of the
Earth's.
The PRIMER V4 is a robot that can walk a tightrope,
unaided. Created by Dr. Guero the robot has
grooved feet that slide along the 4mm thick
steel wire and it maintains its balance using
its arms that react to an inclination sensor
by making quick movements and allowing the
body to stay balanced.
The Quad Ski is the first commercially available
amphibious vehicle to go over 10 mph on land
and in water. It can drive up to 45 MPH on land,
and with the press of a button it takes 5
seconds for the wheels to fold up and tuck
into the sides once it hits the water, where
it then also has the ability go 45 MPH. It's
been in development for almost two decades
and is scheduled to go on sale in the U.S
by the end of the year for around $40,000.
Here's the most detailed picture ever taken of Uranus.
A Beluga Whale was recorded trying to make
human sounds. No one claims that he was trying
to communicate with humans, but most researchers
seem convinced that, at the very least, he
was attempting to mimic the sounds he heard
coming from humans.
These Future Socks will never get a hole,
never droop, or wear out on the bottom. The
Socrates sock company is making men's socks
with Kevlar-Carbon Matrix reinforcements to
make the socks extraordinarily durable. Find
the link below for more information.
Got strange-colored, foul-smelling, or awful-tasting
pee in the 16th century? Diagnose your disease
with this genuine Urine Wheel!
Darpa's Pet-Proto robot can now navigate obstacles.
It uses autonomous decision-making, dismounting
mobility and dexterity, and it's part of the
Darpa Robotics Challenge - the goal being
the development of ground robots capable of
executing complex tasks in dangerous, human-engineered
environments.
NoPhoto is a digital smart license plate frame
that aims to stop camera-based tickets. It
prevents traffic cameras from taking a picture
of your license plate at red lights or speed
traps by blasting the license plate with light,
making it too bright for the camera's sensor
to handle and leaving the image overexposed.
They claim it's perfectly legal, and that
traffic enforcement cameras are an invasion
of privacy - find the link below to read more.
Finally, Hominid is an X-ray style animation
created by Brian Andrews at the Expression
College for Digital Arts of animal human hybrids...
I'm gonna leave you with a dancing baby stingray
and, as always, thanks for watching.
[Drops on Drops on Drops]
["When falling onto another liquid layer, water droplets typically bounce then coalesce.]
[If the surface is vibrating, however, the droplets will continue bouncing, as seen in this video."]